[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara halbwegs guten abend und
willkommen an diesem ostersamstag oder
zahn ist auch wieder dabei für den sport
sehr gerne schönen guten abend und das
sind einige der themen von heute
lob aber auch kritik an zusätzliche
militärhilfe für die ukraine für manche
ein guter erster schritt die union will
weiter die lieferung schwerer waffen
private über ostermärsche zehntausende
demonstrieren für frieden die
pazifistische botschaft stößt aber auch
auf ablehnung und
trauer um joachim streich der
rekordtorschütze des ddr fußballs ist im
alter von 71 jahren gestorben
seit tagen wächst der druck auf die
bundesregierung auch schwere waffen in
die ukraine zu liefern fdp und grüne
sind dafür der bundeskanzler hält sich
in dieser frage bedeckt und bildet erst
mal einen weiteren milliarden topf für
die rüstungs hilfe ein großteil soll der
ukraine zu gute kommen doch nicht nur
die union sagt es brauche mehr nicole
diekmann viel wurde in den vergangenen
tagen über ihn geredet über den
schützenpanzer marder schweres gerät an
die ukraine ja oder nein die
bundesregierung hat sich stattdessen für
eine erhöhung der ertüchtigung
initiative entschieden ein wortungetüm
hinter dem rund eine milliarde euro für
die ukraine steckt die ersten kritiker
besänftigt das bedeutet die ukraine kann
dann aussuchen was sie glaubt an waffen
material was sie braucht wir stellen
mittel zur verfügung um das
gegebenenfalls auf dem markt einzukaufen
wenn wir es nicht selber liefern können
also das ist der richtige schritt strack
zimmermann war diese woche überraschend
in die ukraine gereist unter anderem mit
anton hofreiter von den grünen beide
übten scharfe kritik am kanzler
hofreiter bleibt bei seiner haltung
das ist ein erster schritt aber ist es
natürlich kein ersatz für die direkte
lieferung schwerer waffen und es ist
auch kein ersatz dafür putin vom
geldzufluss abzuschneiden das heißt
energie embargo insbesondere öl embargo
muss weiter auf der tagesordnung bleiben
schwere waffen an die ukraine auch die
cdu erneuert heute diese forderung sie
nennt das geld aus der ertüchtigung
initiative augenwischerei der schnellste
weg wäre wenn deutschland heute waffen
lieferte anstatt der ukraine geld zu
geben damit sie kauft in deutschland ein
waffen exportgeschäft beantragen muss
das genehmigt werden muss die wahrheit
ist doch bundeskanzler scholz will es
nicht und es ist ein weiterer versuch es
zu verhindern kritik von vielen seiten
nur vier monate nach amtsantritt steht
kanzler scholz bereits unter druck
parteifreunde stellen sich demonstrativ
hinter ihn ich glaube dass zu den
stärken von olaf scholz auch gehört dass
er besonnenheit
pflegt und weniger die
perfekte in den vordergrund stellt an
den anderen meer gelegen sein mag er ist
da sehr zurückhaltend und besonnen
führungsschwäche im kanzleramt schwere
waffen für die ukraine beide debatten
gehen in die nächste runde ende vorerst
nicht in sicht
der krieg könne verkürzt werden wenn die
ukraine rasch alle gewünschten waffen
geliefert bekommen davon ist ihr
präsident überzeugt weiterhin fordern
die ukrainischen behörden im osten des
landes die bevölkerung zur evakuierung
auf solange das noch möglich sei also
vor der erwarteten russischen offensive
doch auch andere teile der ukraine
wurden wieder angegriffen volker jack
hat mir
mitten am tag mitten im wohngebiet
schlagen die artilleriegeschosse ein und
treffen wahllose spaziergänger
fahrradfahrer
gestern in kharkiv der zweitgrößten
stadt des landes unweit der russischen
grenze
diese familie hat glück gehabt aber der
schock welt vor allem carolina und wird
es wohl noch lange tun
es fühlte sich ganz nah an das geschoss
flog vorbei ist knallte eine frau warf
sich auf mich um mich zu schützen
ihre mutter versucht sie zu trösten
seine nicht meine kleine es ist vorbei
alles vorbei
wie viele zivilisten in dem krieg
getötet wurden niemand weiß es genau von
rund 13.000 opfern unter den
ukrainischen soldaten spricht präsident
selensky bis zu 3000 tote 10.000
soldaten zum teil schwer verletzt
zielinski verlangt neue sanktionen
das nächste paket muss ein importverbot
von russischem öl enthalten
die demokratische welt muss einsehen
dass geld für russische energie
eigentlich geld für die zerstörung der
demokratie ist
das russische verteidigungsministerium
meldet heute auch angriffe auf mikko
live im süden auf lager für raketen und
artillerie am rand der region donetsk
und lohans sammeln sich seit tagen
russische einheiten die ukrainischen
behörden rechnen damit dass sie in
beiden gebieten gleichzeitig losschlagen
werden schon bald mitte der woche wenn
der regen aufhört
aus der region um hier hatten sich die
russischen truppen zurückgezogen doch
jetzt nimmt moskau die hauptstadtregion
wieder verstärkt ins visier mit
luftangriffen wie die menschen dort
damit umgehen zeigt aus kiew dominik les
meister
wieder raketeneinschläge in kiew das
ziel laut russische militär eine
panzerfabrik die ukraine sprechen von
einem toten und mehreren verletzten die
anspannung steigt in der stadt auch bei
danny a sie ist deutsche übersetzerin
zusammen mit ihrem mann ist sie gerade
erst nach kiew zurückgekehrt aus dem
westen der ukraine nach westen sicher
ist was man nicht weil die gerüchte
kommen dass der durch cent wiederkommen
wollen statt besiegen
wir hoffen sie können es nicht einen
regelrechten run gibt es seit gestern
auf diese briefmarke sie zeigt einen
ukrainischen soldaten der dem russischen
kriegsschiff moskwa ein eindeutiges
zeichen gibt seit dem untergang ein
kultobjekt irina hat heute morgen die
letzten marken bekommen
und die schicke briefe mit dieser marke
an meine freundin holen die orgien und
deutschland sie so stark die ukraine
unterstützen
so sind trotz der neuen luftschläge auf
kreisstraßen und den parks wieder mehr
menschen zu sehen die russischen
angriffe hatten seit ende märz
eigentlich abgenommen doch jetzt heulen
die sirenen wieder in der hauptstadt
jeden tag bürgermeister klitschko
forderte inzwischen die menschen auf
nicht wieder nach kiew zurück zu kehren
und an sicheren orten zu bleiben doch
immer mehr verkommen zurück in ihre
stadt trotz der gefahr sie wollen sich
von putin nicht ihr leben diktieren
lassen
mehr als
350.000 geflüchtete aus der ukraine sind
inzwischen in deutschland registriert
doch auch aus russland suchen menschen
hier schutz bürgerrechtler kritische
journalisten oder kulturschaffende auch
ihnen sollen langwierige asylverfahren
erspart werden das kündigte
justizminister buschmann in der welt am
sonntag an ziel sei es dass sie schnell
eine arbeitserlaubnis erhalten
wirtschaftsminister habeck von den
grünen fordert von den teilnehmern der
ostermärsche eine klare botschaft an
russland es sei eindeutig wen
deutschland unterstützen müsse auch mit
waffen pazifismus sei aktuell ein ferner
traum sagt harwig der erste deutsche
ostermarsch liegt lange zurück am 15
april
1960 gingen atomwaffengegner auf die
straße der beginn einer neuen bewegung
zeitweise mit hunderttausenden
demonstranten
heute waren bundesweit 80
veranstaltungen geplant jan frederik iv
schluss mit russlands angriff auf die
ukraine ein rückzug aller russischen
truppen die teilnehmer des ostermarsches
stuttgart wollen ihre volle solidarität
mit der ukraine zeigen laut veranstalter
sind 2500 menschen gekommen gerade jetzt
wo in europa krieg herrsche sei es umso
wichtiger zu demonstrieren erklären
viele von ihnen doch die bewegung steckt
in einem dilemma umfasst die solidarität
auf waffenlieferung gar eine abkehr vom
pazifismus nein sagen viele die waffen
die jetzt geliefert werden verlängern
den krieg verlängern das leid wo sind
diejenigen die jetzt verhandeln gehen
keine waffenlieferungen keine aufrüstung
gar nichts in diese richtung frieden
doch einig sind sie sich nicht mit blick
auf butter und andere gräueltaten
scheint etwas ins wanken zu geraten alte
überzeugungen werden mitunter in frage
gestellt bin selber mit einem ganz ganz
großem zwiespalt heute hier weil ich
durchaus sehe dass man die
völkerrechtswidrige und auch
menschenverachtende gewalt in der
ukraine stoppen muss auch mit waffen ich
bin an sich auch gegen waffen nur ich
glaube dass man der situation
entsprechend reagieren sollte und die
situation gibt es glaube ich gerade
nicht her dass man weiterhin einfach nur
nett redet die friedensbewegung muss
antworten suchen sagen experten denn in
der aktuellen lage habe der pazifismus
wenig zu bieten vielmehr wirkte er
zynisch das potenzial wäre jedoch der
bewegung hat eine riesige strahlkraft
werden sie denn viele leute auf die
straße bringt momentan ist es allerdings
so dass es gar nicht so eine starke
botschaft gibt die verstanden werden
könnte vielen ist die problematik
bewusst man müsste die themen
diskutieren doch heute beim ostermarsch
ist erstmal eines wichtiger auf die
straße zu gehen gegen den krieg
mehr zur aktuellen debatte über die
ostermärsche und die haltung der
friedensbewegung zum ukraine krieg
finden sie auf zdf heute und in der zdf-
heute- app ein zeichen des friedens
wollte auch papst franziskus setzten
gestern abend bei der traditionellen
kreuzweg andacht in rom an der
dreizehnter station im kolosseum
übernahmen zwei frauen gemeinsam das
holzkreuz eine ukrainerin und eine
russin irina und albina befreundet der
krankenschwestern scharfe kritik gab es
dafür vor allem aus der ukraine
das sei eine verfrühte versöhnungsgeste
zu corona da sinken die infektionszahlen
weiter allerdings werden wegen der
feiertage weniger daten übermittelt das
meldet 37 1568 neue infektionen
innerhalb eines tages das sind
113.000 107 weniger als vor einer woche
29 todesfälle kamen binnen 24 stunden
hinzu die sieben tage incidents sinkt
erstmals seit ende januar unter 1000 und
liegt jetzt bei 8
176,5
ein referendum über europa so nennt
frankreichs präsident makro die
entscheidende zweite runde der
präsidentenwahl morgen in einer woche in
der ersten runde kam der amtsinhaber auf
knapp 28 prozent seine konkurrentin die
rechtspopulistin marine le pen auf gut
23 die stichwahl könnte richtig eng
werden deswegen müssen beide jetzt noch
stimmen aus allen politischen lagern
gewinnen mehr von christel haas
viele einwohner von max hätten lieber
einen linksaußen politiker in der
stichwahl gesehen nun müssen sie sich
neu entscheiden
ich wähle lippen punkt fragen sie nicht
warum alle anderen sind korrupt
warum ich makro welle um nicht rappen zu
wählen und um die rechten zu verhindern
ich bin ratlos wahrscheinlich gebe ich
einen leeren wahlzettel ab oder ich
enthalte mich nicht umsonst hat im makro
heute hier einen großen auftritt
die rechtsextremen wollen die deutsch
französische freundschaft beenden und
eine militär allianz mit russland ihr
müsst sie am 24 april besiegen marine le
pen gibt sich siegessicher die verbalen
angriffe gegen sie seien ein gutes
zeichen
das bestätigt dass ich die wahl gewinnen
kann die brutalität gegen mich steigt
genauso stark wie meine chancen in
diesem rennen zu siegen
frankreich gegen frankreich titelt an
magazin so tief gespalten war das land
wohl noch nie jüngste umfragen sehen
makro zwar knapp vorn doch viele
franzosen sind noch unentschieden und
sie könnten das zünglein an der waage
sein
lob an makro haut ab skandieren sie
heute in paris und anderswo zehntausende
demonstrieren gegen rechts aber auch der
amtierende präsident kommt nicht gut weg
wir sind gegen die verharmlosung der
rechtsextremen und auch dagegen dass wir
zwischen einem rechtsliberalen und einer
rechtsextremen wählen müssen
frankreich 8 tage vor der stichwahl egal
wer gewinnt es wird schwer die
gegensätze zu überbrücken
mehr als zwei jahre ist es her dass
prinz harry das britische königshaus
verließ jetzt zeigte sich erstmals
wieder gemeinsam mit seiner frau mergen
öffentlich in europa und zwar in den
niederlanden zum auftakt der von ihnen
gegründeten invictus games ein
paralympischer wettbewerb für
kriegsversehrte auch veteranen aus der
ukraine sind dabei eine klinik hat mir
sie sind eine herzensangelegenheit des
britischen prinzen harry die in victor's
games übersetzt die spiele der
unbesiegbaren zusammen mit seiner frau
megan ist er nach den haag gekommen um
den wettbewerb für kriegsverletzte am
abend zu eröffnen gestern schon hatten
sich die royals als zeichen der
solidarität mit der ukrainischen
mannschaft getroffen viele der sportler
kommen direkt aus dem krieg sowie der
bogenschütze wolodimir musik der nach
einer minenexplosion unter einem
schädeltrauma leidet
wir kommen von der front und ich bin
mental immer noch bei meinen kameraden
die jetzt weiterkämpfen nach den
wettbewerben gehe ich sofort zurück um
unser land zu verteidigen
die ukrainischen bogenschützen müssen
ohne ihren trainer in den wettkampf
gehen die mit rossi druck fiel anfang
april im krieg gegen russland eine
weitere sportlerin ist aus mariupol
vermutlich nach russland verschleppt
worden es sind diese geschichten die die
ukrainische mannschaft von hier aus der
welt erzählen will und gleichzeitig
versuchen die athleten auch ein signal
der zuversicht zu senden
große gefühle verbinden mich mit diesen
spielen der sport gab mir wieder kraft
zu leben vorher sah sich am computer und
habe das haus nicht verlassen
ich habe mich total abgekapselt
veteranen aus 20 ländern messen sich in
den nächsten tagen in verschiedenen
disziplinen und werden den krieg in der
ukraine
der neue traumata und verletzte
hervorbringt nicht aus ihren köpfen
verdrängen können
tja jetzt bist du dran mit fußball und
tennis saison endspurt in der fußball
bundesliga am 30 spieltag zeigt sich
borussia dortmund in torlaune und feiert
vor fast 80.000 zuschauern einen
beeindruckenden sieg
die vier ergebnisse von heute nachmittag
dortmund gewinnt also 6 zu 1 gegen
überforderte wolfsburger augsburg hertha
bsc 0 21 wichtiger sieg für magaths
berliner im abstiegskampf keine tore im
spiel mainz gegen vfb stuttgart freiburg
gewinnt gegen bochum drei zu null das
rheinische derby gladbach gegen köln
ausführlich im aktuellen sportstudio
in der tabelle hat dortmund den abstand
hinter münchen zumindest bis morgen auf
sechs punkte reduziert leverkusen und
leipzig sind ebenfalls morgen gefördert
mainz von zehn auf neun
spannend der kampf um den klassenerhalt
härter hat sich durch den sieg auf den
15 rang verbessert stuttgart wird auf
dem relegationsplatz wieder auf dem
relegationsplatz abgeschlagen kräuter
führt
jede menge fußball am abend dann im
aktuellen sportstudio ab 23 uhr gast bei
sven voss ist bochums torwart manuel
riemann
der ehemalige weltklassestürmer und
rekordtorjäger joachim streich ist im
alter von 71 jahren nach schwerer
krankheit verstorben streich galt als
ikone des ddr fußballs und erzielte 229
treffer für magdeburg und hansa rostock
joachim streich zum hundertsten von
insgesamt 102 länderspielen geehrt im
londoner wembley stadion ein
strafraumspieler par exellence
erfolgreich gegen das dfb team bei
olympia 72 in münchen artistisch zwei
jahre später bei der wm
55 länderspiel tore sprechen für sich
ein spieler mit seltenen gaben man muss
ganz einfach auch ein bisserl den
instinkt haben wie man vom tor braucht
man muss natürlich taktisch und
technisch gut ausgebildet seien und dann
ja einfach nicht so viel überlegen als
spieler in rostock und magdeburg
erfolgreich als trainer danach weniger
sportartikel vertreter wurde er
schließlich kurz nach seinem 71
geburtstag erlag joachim streich einem
krebsleiden
alexander zverev ist im halbfinale des
atp tennis turniers von monte carlo
ausgeschieden gegen den an nummer drei
gesetzten stefanos city pass hatte zwölf
schon den ersten satz mit 4 6 ab gegeben
im zweiten wurde die überlegenheit von
zipp assen noch deutlicher der grieche
gewann mit 6 2 und trifft morgen im
finale auf den spanier alessandro
davidovitch china
und deutschlands tennis frauen haben die
finanz beim billie jean king cup in
kasachstan klar verpasst und spielen nun
gegen den abstieg
angelique kerber verlor durch das 6 4 3
6 und 5 7 gegen die kasachische
spitzenspielerin je länger die bank ihn
auch ihr zweites einzel und konnte nicht
für die wende sorgen nach drei
niederlagen lag das dtb-team
aussichtslos zurück
schade eigentlich
danke schön trotzdem sehr gerne und noch
ein ausflugstipp für alle denen die
ostereiersuche zu langweilig ist das
fränkische klein hawaii für alle surfer
die neue fuchsloch welle in nürnberg
heute und morgen schwingen sich die
profis aufs brett bei den
meisterschaften im rapid- kaffee
und das wetter bleibt auch am
ostersonntag sehr angenehm mild mit viel
sonne details hat gleich katja um
viertel vor elf meldet sich marietta
slomka mit dem heute-journal wir danken
ihnen für ihr interesse und wünschen
ihnen allen noch ein schönes
osterwochenende morgens
[Musik]
guten abend zum wiederholten mal wird
saharastaub weit nach norden
transportiert sie sehen dass hier schon
an der luft trübung über dem mittelmeer
der sahara staub hat bereits das
südliche italien erreicht bei uns wurden
die wolken der gegenrichtung süden
getrieben hier an die alpen am frühen
morgen erkennen sie noch ein schmales
wolkenband über frankreich vor allen
dingen an dem schatten den dieses
wolkenband brav über tag gab es dann
viel sonnenschein von der ostseeküste
bis zum oberrhein und auch jetzt in der
nacht bleibt es meist klar und nur im
nordosten sind einige wolkenfelder
unterwegs ist wird kalt die temperaturen
sinken auf plus 4 bis minus 4 grad fast
überall wird es also noch mal kalt genug
für bodenfrost die das west-ost-gefälle
bei den temperaturen gibt es auch morgen
über tag im westen steigen die werte auf
15 bis 20 grad im osten sind es nur 10
bis 15 grad und es wird ein sehr
sonniger ostersonntag höchstens im osten
gibt es ein paar quellwolken bei einem
leichten bis mäßigen wind aus
unterschiedlichen richtungen wenn ihnen
morgen was in der nase kribbelt dann
könnte das der birkenpollen sein denn
die birkenpollen konzentration ist
morgen in deutschland extrem am
ostermontag ändert sich an diesem wetter
wenig dienstag und mittwoch könnte es im
süden für etwas regenreichen frohe
ostern